ein schiff im morgen zu einem richtigen
fragen spezial mit dem mann der jetzt
neuer spd chef ist seit diesem
wochenende
herr klink mal sind sie schon umgezogen
willy brandt haus noch nicht gibt können
und paar andere dinge zu tun dass man
alles im januar in ruhe wir haben gerade
die diskussion über die frage gesehen
wie schnell das impfen vorankommt was
wir tun können wovon gehen sie aus wann
müssen sich das nächste mal irgendwie
müssen wir uns jetzt alle vier fünf
monate impfen dauert das ein jahr wie
wird das ausgehen ich glaube dass wir
alle klug beraten sind da jetzt keine
definitiven aussagen zu treffen wir
müssen lernen als gesellschaft insgesamt
als politik ja ich glaube wir haben in
den vergangenen monaten viel zu viel
definitiven aussagen gemacht wann das
alles vorbei ist wann man endgültig
geimpft ist wann man über den berg ist
und wir sehen dass das virus diese
definitiven aussagen nicht zuletzt wir
erleben neue varianten wir erleben impft
durchbrüche wir sehen dass manche
erfolge sich nicht so einstellen wie wir
sie uns erhofft hatten und deswegen rate
ich ein bisschen zu vorsichtigen
kommunikation den menschen offen zu
sagen dass wir alle lernen gerade und
dass wir uns jeden tag neu fragen müssen
tun wir das richtige ist glaube ich die
bessere kommunikation die größte debatte
diese woche haben wir wirklich genug
impfstoff karl lauterbach sagt nein
inventur hat ergeben es gibt nicht
genügend aber die debatte ist groß
welche zahlen da jetzt wirklich stimmen
was ist sache das ist jetzt seinem
verantwortungsbereich von karl
lauterbach das ist richtig dass er jetzt
erst mal genau prüft wie viel es da wir
sind gerade alle sehr sehr froh dass
sich so viele menschen impfen lassen die
erstimpfung nehmen zu vor allem über die
booster impfung da haben wir gerade
rekordzahlen also das ist ja was sehr
positiv ist dass so viele menschen auch
sagen wir wollen jetzt bewusst werden
muss dann eben doch der weg jetzt ist
durch diese vierte welle durchzukommen
je mehr menschen sich boostern lassen
desto besser ist das und jetzt muss karl
lauterbach gucken dass wir dann dieses
delta dass sie anscheinend gerade da es
ich habe gestern die zahl gehört er geht
von 70 millionen impfdosen aus die wir
brauchen 50 sind anscheinend da noch mal
das sind die zahlen sich jetzt auch
gehört habe wäre schuld dass wir
möglicherweise das gehen und
imprägnieren herunter es geht ja nicht
um schuld aber das waren sich die
menschen ja wenn es geht dann erst mal
in bekommt es passiert erstmal ja darum
dass das boostern massiv an bedeutung
gewonnen hat sagt auch das war inklusive
mir fielen gar nicht klar dass auf
einmal zum beispiel war es weniger die
wirkung nach zwei bis vier monaten schon
nach lässt also da hat die stiko ja auch
immer die empfehlung gehabt nach sieben
nach sechs monaten sollen sich die über
70-jährigen da sind jetzt andere
empfehlungen ausgesprochen worden also
da sind dinge auch zu langsam
kommuniziert worden aber dass da ja beim
64 das produkt anlassen sound und jetzt
muss geguckt werden das kann auch im
schafft das aber ich bin mir sicher karl
lauterbach kriegt das hin aber was ist
mit der produktion von impfstoff man
hätte ja einfach sagen können okay wir
helfen noch weitere fabriken zu bauen
würden machen das maximale und wir
produzieren so viel dass wir am ende
dann entscheiden können okay dann
verschenken wir den rest ich glaube es
geht gar nicht mehr um die frage von
produktionsstätten da sind ja viele
aufgebaut worden da ist ja wirklich auch
verbessert worden die situation aber wir
haben in den letzten wochen doch auch im
stoff verfallen lassen weil nicht genug
geimpft wurde jetzt ziehen die impfung
wieder an das ist gut aber nochmal karl
lauterbach rede selbst sehr viel mit ihm
es gerade 24 stunden im einsatz für mehr
impfstoff und ich hoffe und gehe davon
aus dass wir das delta auffüllen können
was jetzt gerade entsteht in der frage
haben wir genug impfstoff große debatte
im pflicht sie haben bereits betont sie
sind dafür jetzt hören wir von
fdp-abgeordneten wolfgang kubicki da
gibt es ein sturm dagegen haben sie
sorge dass es am ende für ihren vorstoß
keine märkte das glaube ich nicht weil
ich noch mal es ist eine
gewissensentscheidung und parlament da
zählen dann keine partei und
fraktionsgrenzen und ich bin ja auch zu
diesem punkt gekommen also auch von mir
finden sie aussagen aus den letzten
monaten wo ich mich sehr skeptisch
gegenüber nicht äußern aber nochmal wir
haben neue virusvarianten wir sehen das
nimmt auch nur bei 70 prozent liegt wir
sehen dass jetzt gerade wieder eine
phase ist chemotherapien verschoben
werden wo lebensnotwendige operationen
verschoben werden und da muss jetzt eine
klarheit sein für die fünfte für die
sexuelle und das wird nun endlich gehen
aber ist doch absurd dass wir über eine
impfpflicht diskutieren und gleichzeitig
ihr gesundheitsminister sei es gibt gar
nicht genügend impfstoff
dann muss man mehr im stoff besorgen
darum geht es doch jetzt aber da war
eine debatte über die impfpflicht und
sollen gleichzeitig es gibt gar nicht
genügend impfstoff sollte man nicht dass
eine vor dem anderen lösen bevor man das
tun wir brauchen eine rechtliche
klarheit was die frage
impfpflicht angeht und das kann keine
sache übrigens sein die man mal eben so
in ein oder zwei sitzungswochen und
deutschen bundestages knie bricht es
muss gesellschaftlich diskutiert werden
wir haben ja gerade eine situation zeige
ich ihnen auch wo diejenigen die sich an
die regeln halten diejenigen die jetzt
zum dritten mal sich am bustan lassen
gegen die auf abstand bleiben diejenigen
die alles das tun was politik bietet
seit jetzt 20 monaten dass die auch
sagen liebe leute führt jetzt diese
impfpflicht ein wir wollen endlich durch
die pandemie durchkommt kann nicht sein
dass ein kleiner teil dieser
gesellschaft sagt wir machen
es geht ja darum schreibe schreibe eine
gesellschaftliche debatte
und da muss politik lösungen daraufhin
und deswegen ist die frage wird das eine
frage haben wir genug impfstoff und das
werden wir sicherstellen da ist karl
lauterbach dran und es wird genug
impfstoff geben aber es muss jetzt
nachgearbeitet werden es muss
nachbestellt während wann gibt es
genügend impfstoff sie wissen selbst
dass karl lauterbach jetzt viel im
gespräch ist dass der im gespräch ist
auch mit anderen ländern mit den
impfstellen wann er genug impfstoff hat
das muss er beantworten aber ich weiß
dass er hat jeden tag 24 stunden daran
arbeitet die kanzler olaf scholz sagt
die gesellschaft ist nicht gespalten
weil die große mehrheit sich impfen
lässt wo bleibt eigentlich das herz der
spd für minderheiten
erstmal hat olaf scholz völlig recht
damit ich halte diese spaltung debatte
wurde ja so getan wird als ob sich zwei
gleich große gruppen gegenüber stehen
die ist völlig daneben wir haben
millionen ist völlig daneben millionen
hat im wahlkampf selbst vor der spaltung
der gesellschaft gewarnt da kriegen wir
die seit 20 monaten ein weg des
miteinanders der solidarität mit der
sich an alle regeln halten das gift als
spd wähler und herrnsheimer es gibt eine
kleine radikale gruppe von menschen die
sich drei spd will er dann auch eine
radikale minderheit es gibt eine kleine
gruppe von wenigen tausend die sich
gerade radikalisiert mit fackeln
menschen mit mord aufrufen die auf terim
organisiert werden das ist ja noch da
darf man nichts zu tun als ob das jetzt
auf einmal eine gleich große gruppe
sowie der ihnen die solidarischen wir
müssen besser werden wir müssen besser
werden bei menschen die nicht geimpft
sind die aber überzeugt werden können
ich glaube da gibt es eine gruppe das
hat damit zu tun dass noch besser
argumentiert wird das hat damit zu tun
dass zum beispiel auch in andere
sprachen übersetzt wird das gezielt in
stadtviertel reingegangen wird wo es
vielleicht auch eine skepsis gegenüber
dem münchen gibt also da ist
kommunikation aber richtig ist aber dass
ich jetzt ab sie gehen bei uns heimisch
beschreiben
welche teile es geht und werde alle
teile muss man redet über die
ungeimpften und da gab es stand anfang
der woche eine statistik die zeige das
ist mehr ungeimpfte als spd wähler gibt
aber das ist eine frage was eigentlich
warte was ist der wert dieser aussage
der wert dieser aussage ist dass das
keine kleine minderheit ist weil dann
müsste man ja sagen eine minderheit hat
olaf scholz um kanzler gehört ich glaube
aber dass von denen die jetzt ungeimpft
sind das hat ja nichts zu tun mit der
radikalisierung die wir erleben sondern
da geht es um menschen die müssen
gezielt angesprochen werden die müssen
überzeugt werden dann müssen nochmal
argumente durchgesetzt ich merke dass
selbst bei mir im wahlkreis 1
bürgersprechstunden dass sich bei mir
menschen melden die zum beispiel sagen
ich lasse mich nicht impfen
junge frauen weil sie angst haben dass
sie keine kinder bekommen können sind da
bin ich fest von überzeugt dass durch
eine ordentliche aufklärung das durch
argumente dass durch wissenschaftliche
belege warum dann das solche dass solche
dinge auch dass solche dinge dann auch
noch mal umgebogen werden können das
überzeugt werden kann davon gehe ich
fest aus aber wir leben auch die
radikalisierung die pflicht glaube ich
weil es noch mal deutlich macht in
welcher dramatik sich dieses land
befindet und wir uns überhaupt in einer
lage befinden noch einmal verschieben
gerade chemo therapien wie verschieben
gerade lebensnotwendige operationen wir
kommen nicht aus dem krisenmodus raus
und impfen ist der weg raus aus diesem
krisenmodus und das muss jeder begreifen
es ist eine frage auch von solidarität
in diesem land ob man sich impfen lässt
oder nicht oder shirts hat in dieser
woche gesagt oder hat sich an kritisiert
das ist eine winzige minderheit enthemmt
der extremisten gebe und die wehrhafte
demokratie
dagegen in stellung gebracht aber was
soll da jetzt passieren außer ansprachen
außer reden gegen diese menschen gibt es
da auch gesetzesmaßnahmen die sie
beschließen wollen gibt es da initiative
also erstmal ist klar wenn man sich
einreiht in die wenigen die da unterwegs
sind mit fackeln die versuchen andere
einzuschüchtern die journalistin
angreifen dann muss jedem klar sein mit
wem man da marschiert und das hat
überhaupt nichts mit einer debatte über
coma politik konsequenzen sollte dass
wir die konsequenz punkt eins ist
erstmal und das erwarte ich auch von den
sicherheitsbehörden mit denen diskutiert
man nicht sondern da muss hart
durchgegriffen werden da sieht man
übrigens noch große unterschiede
zwischen bundesländern bremen
niedersachsen wird hat durchgegriffen in
sachsen erlebe ich dass polizei
diskutiert mit solchen leuten und das
gibt den ein falsches verständnis davon
dass sie irgendwo doch etwas
berechtigtes tun aber nochmal wer mit
fackeln marschiert der tut also der tut
etwas was hoch unanständig ist wo
grenzen überschritten sind und was man
nicht tun darf und jetzt geht es in der
tat um zb telegramm stärker in den fokus
zu nehmen das kann man ja mal wir müssen
ein telegramm einstufen als soziales
netzwerk damit gilt das netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz was wir auf den weg
gebracht haben und das ermöglicht uns
eben doch rechtlich härter vorzugehen
gegen solch eine plattform und es geht
ja bis dahin dass gerade diskutiert wird
auch von boris pistorius von nancy
faeser von anderen ob nicht die großen
amerikanischen player eine platte 1 1
ein dienstleister wie telegramm aus den
app stores rausnehmen sollten was aber
wichtig ist und dass sie wollen
telegramm verbieten aber nicht verbieten
aber schon deutlich machen wir erlauben
nicht deren politik das nicht hingucken
da muss der druck erhöht werden und
warum es vor allem geht und das ist das
wichtigste die strafe
ermittlungsbehörden müssten so
ausgestattet sein dass sie das
beobachten was dort passiert und dass
sie dann eingreifen sie haben in dieser
woche durchsuchungen durchgeführt in
sachsen nachdem sich dort menschen
verabredet haben mord aufrufe gestartet
haben aber telegraph wenn ich das
problem das programm ist aber erstmal
die plattform auf der gerade
kommuniziert wird und dann haben sie
recht das ist nur die plattform das ist
nicht das problem aber dann will ich
auch dass die strafermittlungsbehörden
morgens um fünf bei den vor der tür
stehen die dort kommunizieren dass dort
die wohnung durchsucht werden das dann
noch klar es wird anzeige erstattet wenn
man sich dort zum mord aufrufen oder
anderen bedrohungen verabredet auf
diesen plattformen und jeder muss wissen
dass was sich dort schreibe hat eine
unmittelbare konsequenz und am ende
drohte ihm doch gefängnis dass sie uns
immer ein thema sprechen dann können wir
was die welt bewegt ein unabhängiges
deutsches gericht ist jetzt überzeugung
gekommen dass am 23
august 2009 10 im tiergarten ein
asylbewerber aus georgien im auftrag des
russischen staats in aller öffentlich
ermordet wurde und zitat das gericht
sprach wörtlich von staatsterrorismus
sind diejenigen die wladimir putin
losschickt ist die regierung oder die
mir putins ist das staatsterrorismus was
dort passiert also erstmal ist gut dass
es dieses gerichtsurteil gibt es ist gut
dass die außenministerin dann
unmittelbar konsequent gehandelt hat ist
das als staatsterrorismus ich bin ich
kenne das gerichtsurteil ich habe es
nicht gelesen und gesehen habe noch mal
was wäre machen wir was wir erlebt haben
und das ist dann vielleicht auch die
antwort auf ihre frage was wir erlebt
haben ist dass die souveränität
deutschlands dort angegriffen wurde und
deswegen ist wichtig dass auch so
reagiert wie reagiert wurde nochmal das
gericht spricht von staatsterrorismus
das ist die urteilsbegründung sehen sie
das genauso ich habe keinen anlass
deutschen gerichten zu widersprechen
kann man mit staatsterroristen
milliardenschwere geschäfte machen ohne
die eigene moralische integrität zu
bestätigt wir sind mit russland in einer
wahnsinnig schwierigen situation das hat
ja nicht nur mit diesem vorfall zu tun
sondern wir erleben dass gerade täglich
auch an der ukraine es ist richtig dass
gestern auf dem treffen der staats und
regierungschefs eine deutliche sprache
gegen russland gefunden wurde
russland muss wissen dass es
unmittelbare konsequenzen hat wenn sie
weiter so agieren wie sie gerade agieren
sie was für konsequenz das obliegt den
staats und regierungschefs aber gestern
ist deutlich gemacht worden dass es sehr
harte konsequenzen haben wird das muss
russland verstehen wir werden nicht
erlauben dass grenzen geografisch
politisch moralisch überschritten werden
alles das werden wir nicht zulassen und
das wird dann eine harte antwort geben
europas das ist mir auch wichtig dass
europa insgesamt antwort aber klar sind
auch und das ist der zweite punkt der
nicht erwähnen will der dialog mit
russland der bleibt wichtig und der muss
immer auch angeboten werden aber gerade
werden grenzen lass uns über die
konkreten konsequenzen sprechen wenn die
spd sich als partei auch der
menschenrechte und der moral begreifen
zieht das beim 0 2 nicht warum sagen sie
da sind uns geschäfte wichtiger als
einfach mal klare kante zu sein das
stimmt ja nicht doch das stimmt nein das
stimmt nicht und union gemeinsam sie
haben gestern am gestern ein
bundeskanzler olaf scholz erlebte eine
sehr deutliche sprache gegen deutschland
an als annalena baerbock spricht er sich
nicht dafür aus nord zudem 2002 ist ein
privatwirtschaftliches
vorhaben das jetzt gerade das jetzt
gerade das ist doch kein privat wird
schon eigentlich die wahl hat hat das
unterstützt herunter von man
gerade liegt gerade bei den
genehmigungsbehörden das ist gerade
keine politische entscheidung also eine
juristische entscheidung dass die sp und
es geht doch bei einer frage tiergarten
mord es geht doch in der frage ukraine
gerade um andere zu machen geschäfte mit
staatstheorie sich matthias chef dass
ihre partei macht geschäfte mit stands
terrorismus habe ich weiß dass sie das
so sehen und das ist das auch kein das
ist ja auch so nein es geht um die frage
der politischen konsequenzen gezogen
werden wenn russland sein kurs nicht
ändert da war olaf scholz gestern
deutlich und das zwar sagen sie dann
nicht wenn russland mit den truppen in
die ukraine einmarschiert dann wird es
noch in zwei nicht mehr gibt weil wir
gerade sehr deutlich sagen und doch mal
das hat der sozialdemokratische
bundeskanzler rudolf scholz in aller
klarheit in aller deutlichkeit gestern
mit makro mit den anderen staats und
regierungschefs aus europa deutlich
gemacht wenn russland sein kurs nicht
ändert dann wird es unmittelbar
politische konsequenzen aber wir sehen
ja das ist wladimir putin nicht
beeindruckt wir sehen ja dass
hunderttausende truppen ob nicht weil
die sätze gestern gesprochen wurden in
einer großen europäischen einigkeit und
ich bin mir sicher das wird doch bei
wladimir putin dazu führen dass er sieht
wie geeint europa gerade ist wie olaf
scholz und immer noch immer kaum gerade
europa hinter sich versammeln und wie
sie deutlich mit einer sprache sie
glauben dass ich lange putin von olaf
scholz abhalten lässt krieg gegen die
ukraine zufällig glaube dass diese
europäische einigkeit wahnsinnig wichtig
ist in der jetzigen situation und das
ist aber auch wichtig ist dass russland
immer wieder diese gesprächsangebote
normandie format minsker abkommen das
sind alles dinge die im raum stehen ist
muss doch ziel von europäischer von
deutscher politik sein dass wir russland
auch immer wieder sagen wir wollen mit
euch an einen tisch wir wollen dass
dieses dieses gegenseitige eskalieren
dieses aufrüsten diese verbal i tät die
gerade auch an die nahrung gegenseitige
eskalation wenn auf der anderen seite
über 100.000 mal das ist eine bewusster
würzen eine brust ist falsch verstehen
dessen was ich gesagt habe ich habe
gerade deutlich adressiert das russland
grenzen überschreitet das russland droht
grenzen zu überschreiten geografische
grenzen politische grenzen moralische
grenzen das ist die analyse aber wir
dürfen nicht und sie können analysieren
als journalist aber wir müssen als
politiker eine politische
analysiert wir müssen eine politische
antwort darauf 1000 politischen und
politischer bildung keine angehalten das
und das ist etwas wo wir in der analyse
gleich sind aber die politische antwort
darauf ist lasst uns an einen tisch
setzen und lasst uns darüber reden wie
wir verhindern dass es dort zu einer
militärischen eskalation kommt und das
bedeutet dass alle ihren anteil dazu
beitragen
letzte frage mit blick aufs neue jahr wo
verbringt lars klingbeil weihnachten wo
sind sie mit ihrer familie und was ist
dann das wichtigste thema im neuen jahr
ist es um ikon ist es russland ist es
ich freue mich jetzt auf ein paar
weihnachtstage die hoffentlich ruhig
sind im kreis der familie bin in meinem
wahlkreis in monster dann bei der bei
der familie meiner frau in nordrhein
westfalen und ich glaube dass das
wichtigste thema im nächsten jahr
natürlich corona mit bleibt dass wir uns
aber auch in dieser regierung wahnsinnig
viel vorgenommen haben was die
modernisierung des landes angeht also
staatsmodernisierung
klimapolitik digitalisierung das hilft
ja auch und das hängt unmittelbar mit
cola zusammen kone hat uns ökonomisch
auch herausgefordert in den letzten
jahren werden viel geld ausgegeben und
jetzt müssen wir gucken dass wir neues
wachstum schaffen dass wir neue
wirtschaftskraft auch in diesem land
schaffen wir wollen stark sein gegenüber
china stark sein gegenüber dem silicon
valley und dafür liegt der
koalitionsvertrag die grundlagen unter
dem titel angst haben sie vor nikon wird
schlimm ich habe keine angst man sollte
generell als politiker auch keine angst
haben aber es wird uns als gesellschaft
herausfordern und wir haben am anfang
darüber geredet den satz zu sagen märz
ist das alles vorbei oder im april ist
das alles vorbei den werden sie von mir
nicht hören weil wir sehen dass dieses
virus hartnäckig ist und als uns als
gesellschaft erfordert wir gelernt wir
werden alles vorbei sein es wird eine
normalität geben mit dem virus da bin
ich mir sicher und wir sind stark genug
als gesellschafter zu schaffen
herzlichen dank lars klingbeil für das
gespräch und damit
gebe ich wieder runter danke für das die
richtigen fragen spezial
[Musik]